how should someone conduct themselves
during the interview I'm sure many
people have tried various things try to
win you over with charm and jokes and
others may just be totally silent and
stoic we always tell me I don't be
nervous how can they not be nervous you
know this is not an audition but of
course it is an audition we're trying to
get a sense of what how effective a
member of a community this person would
be because film is a community as we
said before and also this is the
community our program is a community and
indeed we we have all kinds of superstar
riders come right now as we're sitting
here we have an alumnus Dustin Lance
Black who won the Oscar for milk a few
years ago nice teaching a class here
right now
why do I mention that because we talk
about the nervousness
oh the auditioning we will tell them
there you know it's not an audition but
it but it really is about trying to get
a sense of how well they will be able to
collaborate both with the oh the point I
mentioned the reason I mention Lance his
name is Dustin Lance Black but his pals
: Lance is that we will tell the
students like the students were in his
class now he's not the important kind of
meet the important people to meet other
people around the table as he once was
so in other words you it's like my
classmates at USC there was some very
fancy faculty that came and get to guest
jobs but it was the people around the
table I mean I was sitting around a
table with George Lucas in John Milius
and Walter Murch and Randal Kleiser and
Bob Zemeckis
and Caleb Deschanel the cinematographer
and then on and on and on names that you
know and names that you don't know but
it's these people that you you're making
your relationships with with whom you
will have social relationships with and
also professional relations with down
down the line so
forget exactly what this had to do with
know how to conduct yourself in the
interview and looking for people who who
again seem likely to be able to
collaborate and cooperate and be a good
member of our own screenwriting
community here because just as film as a
community as I said before so also is a
little program we could expand massively
we have so many applications from
qualified writers but we've deliberately
not done that we think this is the right
size we don't want it to become a
tuition mill it's just the right we
admit about 25 to 30 a year it's a
two-year program most about half the
people say a third year so at any given
time there are about 70 people in the
program altogether and there are Oh 65
or 75 people in the program at any given
time but again each of the classes are
just eight writers so we want those
people to be you know generous
contributors to those discussions and to
supporting each other around around the
table so we don't really have preset
questions or anything like that but just
having a chat with the people we don't
mind if they reveal a conversion see
with theatre they want to know who I
like to think they've they've seen a
play or two or more by Tennessee
Williams he was actually a guest speaker
here in my early days imagine in a
dramatic writing program I mean it's
like being in seminary and God comes in
to do a question and answer you know and
on Thursday at 2 o'clock the Lord will
be doing a Q&A in the Redwood rumor
would look something like that we had
Billy Wilder as a guest in it and I
imagine it we milder guesting enough in
a film writing class I had Neil Simon
several times come in he just lives
across the street here you know
beautiful thing about being in LA you
came in to talk about comedy right I
mean Neil Simon talking to writers about
Kyle just well again I want to cry
because it is so amazing
what what happens here the resources
that are available and and all of that
but I'm the question again was how
should someone conduct themselves should
they use the conversation so you're just
judging how they get along in a group
how they interact so it's funny because
the first thing they're wondering when
is should they put on a tie you know and
the jacket oh come more casual how
casual is too casual and so on and you
know the question should I put on a tie
the answer is I don't know it's possible
maybe to cut to come to formal and I
think it's possible to come a little too
laid-back and a little too too familiar
you know I want to air if I were a
student coming for an interview for this
program and I might not put on a tie I
probably wouldn't put on a tie I mean I
go on TV and all of these political talk
shows I don't know where it tie it
yeah I wear a jacket and uh I look nice
my wife tells me which is not an easy
compliment to get from my my bride but
again these are all questions we just
don't know exactly what what the answer
is we're open to surprises and I think
that the biggest mistake that you could
probably make us have a clear agenda for
the meeting you know you want it you
come in to meet with us and you want to
achieve this this this this and this I
don't think so I think you just want to
come in and meet with the people and
hear what they have to say and tell you
know answer any questions that they have
and and so on there's no real way to
real smart way to prepare for it and I
think you could even hurt yourself by
over preparing for it do you think
there's a certain amount of flow without
question it's all about flow like I
think how does the conversation flow
it's heartbreaking for us because a lot
of it most of the interviews go quite
well but when it still doesn't mean that
you're going to be admitted in the
likelihood is he won't be admitted just
as a numbers consideration there are
still more than twice as many people
seeking the slots then that then there
are slots and therefore the likelihood
not just the possibility but the
probability is that you will not be
admitted and you know lots of hearts get
broken
a lot of people think they good enough
for the program they go in a min and
they are good enough for the program
they're not admitted not because they're
not gonna have a program but because of
the these numbers issues you know that I
was was mentioning
you